Another way to perform traffic engineering is with
Multipath Routing, where an operator can establish multiple
paths in advance. This approach applies both to
intra-domain routing, and inter-domain routing. The way this
is done in intra-domain routing is to set
link weights such that multiple paths of equal
cost exist between two nodes in the graph.
This approach is called equal cost multi path.
Thus traffic will be split across paths that
have equal costs through the network. A source
router might also be able to change the
fraction of traffic that's sent along each one
of these paths. Sending for example 35% along
the top path and 65% along the bottom
path. It might even be able to do
this based on the level of congestion that's observed
along these paths. The way that the router would do this is by having
multiple forwarding table entries with different [INAUDIBLE]
stops for outgoing packets to the same destination.